on revient chez nous à trois rivières
les deux suspects du triple homicide
commis hier on parle de deux jeunes de
17 ans ont été accusés de meurtre
prémédité
il faut également face à des accusations
de complot pour meurtre
marie claude julien auxerre était lourde
au palais de justice de trois rivières
dans la salle d'audience remplie à
pleine capacité par les proches des
victimes
plusieurs avaient la larme à l'oeil
lorsque les prévenus ont été amenés dans
le box des accusés il ne montrait aucune
émotion
si ce n'est que l'un d'eux a esquissé un
léger sourire en voyant la foule qui
s'était déplacée
l'avocat de la couronne a déjà demandé à
ce que les jeunes reçoivent une sentence
pour adulte non encore d'un marteau
premier degré pour un adulte
la peine est généralement 25 ans il ya
une disposition dans la loi qui fait que
lorsque la personne avait moins de 27
ans ou 16 ans que le maximum possible
ses 10 ans en est d'éviter libération
conditionnelle sur la rue où le drame
s'est déroulé seuls les deux voitures de
police et la fenêtre fracassé rappelle
les tristes événements c'est à travers
cette fenêtre que les suspects se
seraient préparés à tirer sur les
policiers à leur arrivée c'est la plus
jeune des filles qui a communiqué avec
le 9-1-1
elle aurait été la dernière assassiné
par ailleurs comme des textos pourrait
avoir été échangés entre des victimes et
les accusés le volet numérique de
l'enquète prend toute son importance en
tant qu on y retrouve des preuves il y
en aura je vous dis au conditionnel il
en europe aussi blement si ça devait se
faire
mais évidemment que ces éléments là pour
nous la police pour les amener à la
preuve il faudra les faire corroborer et
non pas que ce soit du ouï dire les
suspects font face à des accusations de
meurtre prémédité de complot pour
meurtre contre les victimes contre la
mère des filles et les policiers
d'autres accusations pourraient
s'ajouter à la liste déjà longue
notamment celle de possession d'armes
l'utilisation d'une arme à feu dans un
dessein dangereux par exemple
est ce que ces armes n'a était autorisée
est ce qu'elle était légale et c'est des
jeunes qui connaissait bien les suspects
sont aussi bouleversé lutter et allez
souriez irié avec nous j'ai jamais
imaginé ferriere polar ou avec les
verriers pour signaler seuls les accusés
seront donc de retour au tribunal le 25
février prochain
ici marie claude julien radio canada
trois rivières